today on stick to football we have
Kentucky dual-threat mr. do it all Lynn
Bowden he's a quarterback he's receiver
just get him the [ __ ] football he's
gonna join us here on stick to football
there is so much going on I'm not gonna
waste any time getting into it but I do
want to remind everybody because y'all
been asking and we've been terrible
promoting this February 29th yes that is
a real day this year from 2:00 to 4:00
leap-year Thank You Melo at 2:00 tea
brewing up ups every four years in
Indianapolis same with the Summer
Olympics I hate you we will be having
our vent from 2:00 to 4:00 we'll be
recording the podcast if you don't know
who Joey Molinaro is yet you're living
under a rock he is doing impersonations
of everyone on Twitter right now most
notably Colin coward he'll be joining us
at the event so we have Joey on the
podcast Connor will be there I hope in
that beautiful Hawaiian t-shirt he's
wearing right now looks good I like it
and we'll be having a good time having a
great time 2 to 4 it's free coming out
with us to D Brewing Company now I like
I said a lot is going on things are
happening happening fast and furious
right now guys the NFL came out Thursday
afternoon as we're recording the owners
have voted to approve a new CBA now what
this means basically is the owners now
have a deal that they want to present to
the players this doesn't mean that
anything has been agreed to it doesn't
mean we're getting 17 games doesn't mean
the playoffs are expanding but they have
a deal that they feel good enough that
now they're gonna give it to the NFL
Players Association which will have a
conference call on Friday and they will
vote so the you know the players council
is gonna vote on Friday guys I there's
not a whole lot to say like we don't
know what else in this deal as of
Thursday at 4:06 p.m. Central Time
but we can feel pretty confident that
the NFL is gonna get 17 games and the
owners have already said we can expand
the playoffs without a new CBA so if
they want to do that they feel like they
can do it yeah I think that is exciting
I don't want it to be watered down much
like the NBA where they let half the
league in to their playoffs but I like
the idea of putting another team in
there it really gives that one team that
wins the conference that advantage of
okay we
are getting the by week we are getting
the home-field advantage so there's
gonna be more football on and I think
that's always good news
I am so OCD that I don't want a 17 game
schedule so I could go without that one
but I think that this some of the
players are gonna look at and hear
pretty soon we're gonna get an idea of
what they want kind of how they
counteroffer this thing but it is good
that they're getting it done early we
don't have to worry about any lockouts
coming up so that's always good news for
football fans too that's the most
important thing to me is that the
conversations are starting that the NFL
seems to be very transparent how serious
they are about not only a longer
schedule but definitely an extra team in
the playoffs and I think for the NFLPA
this is a really good opportunity for
them to counter with things that mean a
lot to them if you're giving that much
an extra game is so much more money each
year an extra playoff team is so much
more money each year this is a really
good opportunity for the NFLPA
to ask for some things that mean a lot
to them lifetime health insurance I
think is one that has to come off the
top from them you know it's gotten that
serious especially if you're playing
those kind of seasons even the season
they play now they should have it so the
counter here is gonna be the most
important part of the story and I will
say to the players I know we have a lot
of players that listen to this podcast
three times a week do not let the NFL
sell you on oh but you're gonna get that
playoff share that money is not anywhere
close if you're the seventh team that
makes a playoff your playoff share is
not worth what your normal regular game
check would be for a normal week so
don't let them sell you on that make
sure you're getting your fair cut the
NFL is not going anywhere they're
printing money right now so and I know
the players have great leadership with
Eric Winston as the president of the
NFLPA we've had him on the show before
they they know what they're doing if I'm
the players I look at this and say why
does the owners why do the owners what
this deal done a year and a half before
it has to be done it really feels like
they're just trying to you know like
float something past the players here
like this if I were a player rep if I'm
Richard Sherman today I'm like what
why is there the urgency what are they
trying to get past us
hopefully I'm just getting old and I'm
becoming a skeptical dick but I think
like if I'm the players I want to know
like why we moving so fast on this I
think you're turning into a pessimist
here Matt usually you're mr. optimist
yeah I don't know I think that they're
gonna do their due diligence so they're
gonna read through this thing they're
gonna figure it out I wouldn't be
surprised if they counter with taking
medical marijuana or marijuana off the
banned substance list they're doing
something like the other leagues are
doing where they just don't test for it
anymore
I think that that is something that
they're gonna counter with like Connor
mention lifetime insurance it's gonna be
interesting to see what the players want
back because I think we've heard the
owners talk for so long about the 17
games and now expanding the playoffs I
want to hear what the players are gonna
counter with and what they want because
they really at least in my opinion I
haven't heard much of what they're gonna
counter with so it'll be interesting to
see what they think a lifetime
healthcare so on I think we're gonna see
a drastic change in drug testing for
marijuana I think the NFL is not gonna
go complete like NBA like oh we're not
testing for it anymore but they are
gonna roll that back to where that the
testing window is probably much smaller
and I bet the penalties are a lot less
top pillow Seraphim NFL Network actually
just tweeted guys that the way this
would work so if there's a 17th game
players would get an extra game check
but it would be capped at $250,000 so
Aaron Rodgers who probably makes a
couple million dollars a game would get
his game check for week 17 cap $250,000
if I'm a second sense I tell the owners
to shove that up their ass right now if
you're the 53rd player on the roster
46th cuz the dumb inactive rule like
this exists I don't want a stoppage but
this is just such a [ __ ] deal like
our guy Patrick my home is about to get
35 million dollars a year that's true
and I say he gets two and a half million
dollars a game now he has to play for a
tenth of that yeah and I you even
mentioned the inactive thing make all 53
guys active like what is the point
they're on the roster make everybody
active I think that that's another
argument that the players can make for
health I mean you want more guys in
there playing special teams taking some
of those reps the inactive thing is just
absolutely ridiculous to me you have 53
guys on the roster 53 guys should be
able
in counterpoint it's no sense it yes I
want to ask you because like Melo still
has a full time job teaching you and I
sit around and watch Twitter all day
amazing depending on where you work the
way you're spinning this right now if
you happen to work for let's just say
and network this owned by the owners
right now you're like this is a good
deal let's sign it right now Pro
Football Talk is like uh what like how
could the players approve this
ESPN's like in the middle just like
everybody get along we don't want to
lose football it is it's crazy I mean I
feel like we're covering politics right
now where you have MSNBC saying one
thing in Fox News saying another and
like we're just stuck in the middle here
wanting like truth and an honest opinion
of what's good for everyone this the
$250,000 is a slap in the face to any
player who makes more than four million
dollars a year which is absolutely
insane and I'm with you all the way that
you bring up the coverage of this how is
that even a conversation right now I
would laugh and hang up the phone if
somebody told me that that's the deal
and here's the best part of it it's
capped at two hundred fifty thousand
dollars but does that mean that the
players that make less would still make
less it's not even like it's helping out
the bottom roster gets so I'm reading
into it it's just like yeah I'll give
this advice to anybody that's following
this on Twitter right now you're gonna
hear a lot of glowing and positive
reports about how this agreement and how
this proposal is moving keep an eye on
where those are coming from and I like
plenty of people that work at the NFL
Network but let's be real here guys it's
becoming it's the same you know the
reports are coming from the same spot
all the time you really need to be
balanced here and realized that there's
gonna be a lot of shitty offers that the
league tries to get through the NFLPA
and this could be a much longer process
than we're actually seeing here and I
just can't get over your not even being
serious when you bring that kind of
argument to the table for the 17th game
it should not be treated like the post
season where everybody makes the same
thing or there's any kind of cap limit
it is an extra football game in the
schedule and needs to be treated with
such if they're making a lot of money
off of this everybody needs a piece of
the [ __ ] pie I
and I can't believe like we are all
getting worked up about this which it's
so not expect this happened but friends
that play in this exactly what Connor
said are you gonna cap how much the
owners make on the 17th game of course
you're no way man
trickle-down economics in the fact that
they're capping it to like like you said
Connor that's ridiculous they're not
gonna go to that other guy right well we
figured it up we're you're gonna write
you a check for a hundred and seventy
nine thousand dollars but we're give you
that 250 it's not gonna happen it's so
that is a [ __ ] thing Matt maybe you
were just a realist here and not the
violinist yeah there are some stuff that
it sounds like maybe the owners you're
just trying to sneak in there like oh
yeah by the way sounds like a lot of
money right but is that's a shitload of
money for a we it is but not to these
guys well yeah your worth is what
somebody's gonna pay you I do want to
shift gears because the NFL Scouting
Combine starts Tuesday I will be in
Indianapolis Monday through Monday
Connor will be coming in Thursday Mel
will be coming in Friday we have a lot
of things planned and I want to
encourage everyone who's not already
following be our gridiron on Twitter and
on Instagram do that now if you're not
already also follow all of us and stick
to football hopefully you're doing that
if you listen to the show but we are
going to be doing a lot of fun things
next week I'll be doing some podcasts
and interviews before Connor gets there
so you're gonna get a podcast from us
you're gonna get one Monday morning
Monday morning Olmsted with all of us
all three of us previewing the combine
you're gonna go on Wednesday morning
Thursday morning Friday morning and then
Monday morning you'll get the one from
our event on Saturday so there will be a
lot of content we're gonna be doing a
lot on social media in terms of like
Instagram stories breaking news a lot of
the rumors so be are is rolling out the
carpet for us this week there should be
a ton of content and always to be our
apps a great place to get all that so I
wanted to let everybody know kind of
what we'll be doing there will be a ton
of shows I'm a ton of content but guys I
was excited this morning because I've
read a Sports Illustrated article that
highlighted the new combine drills and I
feel like the league buried the lead on
this like oh combines going to primetime
BFD oh combine drills are getting
changed now I'm excited mostly because
they actually talked about getting rid
of the bench press which needs to happen
they're not yet but they're working
toward it so some of the new
drills include a smoke route drill for
quarterbacks and wide receivers so
that's awesome because like everyone in
the NFL runs this route now so there's
maybe a smoke route drill and also guys
everything will be time to which I don't
know how much that's gonna help us as
evaluators he's gonna make it a lot more
fun to watch so the W drill gonna be
timed the gauntlet is gonna be timed
they're getting rid of the rabbit drill
that offensive and defensive lineman do
instead they're gonna have D lineman do
the figure eight they're gonna have them
push sleds instead of you know a seven
year old couch holding a bag and it
looks like he's about to die so it does
feel like they're getting better at some
of the drills we were going to see and I
think adding a clock to it is gonna up
the competitiveness for a lot of these
players now I will say I was talking to
some agents Thursday there are a lot of
agents have big-time players who say my
guys not working out this year because
he's not gonna be the guinea pig so if
you're chase young do you want to be the
guinea pig where you wee that agent
doesn't know how to prep you to work out
in prime time the schedule is completely
different than it's ever been
it feels like the league is coming out
with things like this information late
in the process so I'm not saying I was
talking to chase Young's agent it wasn't
I don't think but that's a good example
of someone it is do you want to go out
there and be that guy that's like ah
your chamber tooth like he probably
didn't need to work out anyway
and then these guys are such creatures
of habit they are changing the schedule
everything used to be in the morning now
it's in primetime at night I'm not
rolling chase young out there because
these guys have gotten into the routine
in their habits of this is how we
prepare players for the combine now all
that's changed so if I'm chase young if
I'm a jobber oh if I'm maybe even Jeff a
CUDA no thanks
probably not gonna go I'll go I'll
interview I'll do the medicals I'm not
doing very many drills like maybe if I'm
pretty confident in my 40 I'll run the
40 there but I'm gonna weigh in I'm
gonna do the interviews and that's about
it if I'm a top prospect he has no
reason to I mean we can go through the
list right now guys and I don't know if
they'll let us in to the combine after
we do this but they don't like this now
chase young doesn't need to go Joe
burrow doesn't need to go Jeff Okuda
doesn't need to go Jerry Judy I don't
think he needs to go and I know there's
people on Twitter that are acting
surprised that Jerry's telling people
he's going to run in the for
Three's I'm not he looks like on the
field the guy that's gonna be four three
nine four three eight kind of forty guy
we can go down this list I'll tell you
right now there's a ton of players in
the top fifteen I don't need to see
anything this weekend and I am excited
for the combine mostly for day two
receivers and running backs and of
course how the D bees run and a lot of
things like that but when you talk about
the top of this draft where the
blue-chip players are I'm not really
expected to be surprised at all in there
for medicals and interviews and not the
circus that isn't exactly that stuff of
course but the on-camera stuff whatever
I wrote this on my scouting notebook
comes out Friday morning the stuff you
see on TV is actually the least
important so if if they're hyping it on
TV it probably actually doesn't matter a
whole lot to what we do as evaluators
and speaking of making the NFL mad you
guys know this story I'll tell it on the
podcast cuz I'm feeling a little you
know a little spunky spunky today a
couple years ago someone was like hey
where do you want how do you get in to
watch the drills of the combine and I
said you don't but you're welcome to
come to my hotel room will watch the
drills because they won't let us watch
them the NFL reached out to bleacher
report and said so I guess Matt doesn't
need a credential this year I replied
actually I don't I remember I do I do
this year cuz we're doing radio row but
that year I didn't and I don't think I
picked mine up just out of protests
moving on
speaking of Alabama the video quality
wasn't great but I would encourage
everyone to look this up the Alabama
receivers so Henry rugs Jerry Judy
dvanstaa Smith and Jalen Waddell raced
the Alabama DBS
so two corners two safeties it was not
close Henry rugs run in the air almost
[ __ ] lapped them he's like you know
he's fast and there's a scouting saying
don't count it twice I get it no no no
he's really really fast
yeah he's proven it and like you said
the quality of the tape wasn't very good
but yeah we know Henry rugs is fast we
just talked about Jerry Judy like I
don't want to sleep on a guy that's
gonna run for three for fourth that's
very very fast Devon just Smith I'm not
sure where he's at but I'm gonna guess
he's in that four four range Jalen
Waddell is a low for three guy and I
know he's not drafted
but he is a low for three maybe high for
two guy I don't know what the defensive
backs were thinking no two of the
fastest receivers in the entire nation
and you're gonna run with like who's
McKinney out there running
I think he's are all three of a top
safety yep you're not winning that race
buddy you're the fifth fastest
personalized james looked so slow and
he's not
he looks so slow in this video so not
agree i just i went back to me i
remember when we talked to Jerry at the
Super Bowl and we asked about the wide
receiver group and he's like yeah well
like you know Henry and Jalen they'll
lead the pack and then me and then Smith
and I'm sitting there looking at him
like you're telling me Jalen Waddell
runs with rugs this is yeah and we've
talked to people that think Smith is a 4
for 40 guy like Melo just said so your
last guy is running a poor it's unreal
that group it really is something
special I can't wait to watch also
special I didn't want to do the show
without talking about this the Greg
Robinson
Carey Codd senior year Matt Miller worth
of weed from LA to Louisiana and somehow
ended up in Mexico and had to go through
border control with a commercial-grade
canning system and a hundred and fifty
nine pounds of weed in duffel bags if I
may accidentally wind up in Mexico
you've probably started with 165 pounds
of yeah somewhere in between there six
of it disappeared and you got your ass
in Mexico well I just don't understand
like forget the why is he doing this or
how he ended up at Border Patrol what
was he driving like it's like a rented
Tahoe or something like that
yeah they rented a Tahoe in LA and we're
driving it to Louisiana how do you end
up in El Paso I mean I know I know how
but I understand why bro just open
Google Maps and you're a straight line
to Luise story attempt then there was a
guy who drove his uber like in Louisiana
he hired him flew him to LAX and the guy
was supposed to drive him from LAX to
Louisiana the guy was not I think he
said he had a card too to be a like to
be working in the US but he wasn't a
u.s. resident so there's
that aspect of it on top of this so
homeboy the uber driver just got lost I
think I there's so much more to this
story
oh I think he got really excited about
the new CBA and knew that his player rep
probably gonna go to bat on him from
marijuana
probably didn't expect the 159 s from
your player rep but what a story I don't
understand why obviously there's
probably some intent to sell why are you
still doing this if you're a millionaire
like if I'm a millionaire I'm gonna stop
doing anything else that I need to to
make that little extra money I don't
know I don't get it
I think he's made around 30 million
that's the thing he's he was taken
number two overall and then the Browns
weren't sane enough to give him a nice
deal last year so it's bad he's the
worst criminal of all time it's like
neighs I'm there and then Greg Robinson
amazing I do I want to take like this
summer do some investigative podcasting
in the Greg Robinson 159 pounds of weed
is high on my list and they caught him
at the border right why'd you go to
Mexico man how'd you get across it in
the first place this is a great question
to start with if you google Matt there's
like there has to be a piece of this
story missing cuz like if you google map
LAX to New Orleans you're not going
through Mexico was he a drug mule for
the cartel I'm just doing picking some
up on the way I mean I think if he had a
mule he would have made it without
getting caught the problem was he didn't
have one when you're six foot five three
hundred and thirty pound drug mule I
kind of stand out a little bit amazing
if they had gone up through Arizona in
New Mexico and then across the top of
Texas that have been fine I don't the so
much one of the stop here narcos Greg
Robinson next one episode all right
let's take a break Lynn Bowden when we
come back an hour we're top five I
forgot to tell you guys it's gonna be
our top five game-changers I got offense
Melo got defense and Connor pulled the
short strong a special teams
I guess this week so bombs here yeah
next week we'll make sure you get
something fun we'll be back after this
we promised you amazing interviews all
through the draft process we got a great
one here
call him a quarterback calm a receiver
just don't [ __ ] with him before the
ballgame we have Kentucky's Lynn Bowden
baby thanks for calling it man you're in
the middle of training for the combine
which is next week thanks for taking a
moment for us appreciate y'all for
having me oh man
Lynn we're going through the draft
process right now as you know and I
think the highlight of you and what
you're doing right now is the fact that
you switched in the middle of the season
from receiver to quarterback how do you
think that's gonna affect you in the
draft what questions do you think the
teams will ask you maybe positives and
negatives for both sides I think I think
you helped me a lot you know they got
the they got the seed the competitor I
am you know and then what I grain bring
to the table you know just 14 now who
plays receiver running back quarterback
pleasure tEEN TOP's lady be if needed
you know you know some of the questions
you know you just I get asked often is
what do I want to play you know my
answer pretty pretty simply not just I
just wanna play I don't care what it is
you know I want to be out there
tributing Lynn what was that
conversation like in the middle of the
season because you come out of the gate
in the first five games you have like 30
catches you're on fire you know we know
your returning punts really well doing
everything playing Wildcat quarterback
and then they're like hey we're gonna
need you full-time to play quarterback
just what was that conversation like and
how did you feel about it well you know
it really it happened in a South
Carolina game we was losing 24 nothing
like three minutes left fourth quarter
you know our defense was just had you
got to stop and I was getting ready to
go out for our own home return but I had
Toto suit some life just give me a shot
at one Drive you know at quarterback and
you like yeah what works that works
could it could be you know and premier
we went five plays 30 seconds and four
touchdowns like they're in every every
since that that drive you know never
looked back and I was a quarterback and
then I want to ask you the question that
I think every NFL teams
ask you how'd it feel to land that punch
against Virginia Tech because we loved
it yeah I loved it no it was a little
out of character
you know stuff happens but no you just
you can't poke poke the bear
you came you can't you know can't take
what's coming so this is your chance you
get to put the story out there what
caused the scuffle because I believe if
I if I remember right it happened before
the officials even got to the field what
caused that scuffle with Virginia Tech
you know just a bit of thing from the
whole week you know there was they were
kind of like to me I think the game plan
was to try to get me kicked out the game
you know they they knew they really did
have a have a shot at really beating us
with me in the game so whole week they
try to mess with me you know and I'm not
really a guy that's gonna go out and you
know go back and forth with you you know
but so we went Sunday I wanna say we're
gonna Sunday went to NASCAR and like our
changes there at the same time so we was
pulling up when they was leaving and
like we got 150 people on our team it
was four of us and the rest of the team
was up there with you and off the bus
late you know day whole team coaches and
all painters everybody included you know
they start running up on us 460 of them
and four of us so we standing our ground
you know and then from on air every time
they seen us and we seen them you know
it was just just conversation back and
forth for dinner at the game I take a
pregame left every game no matter what
man you know they got the pomp of me
saying stuff to me so you know I'm mad
already because that morning the morning
of the game I get a call from a
girlfriend you know and she tells me
somebody bust out the windows to my car
and it took out my cook all my clothes
all my money took all her clothes and
took all my son clothes cuz we packed to
come down to Pensacola Florida for the
train and you know so I was already up
kind of emotional man at the middle of
the field a it just got getting rowdy
you know you know I'm a man you know I'm
a man first you know prize prize goes a
long way and you know I just
like they was punking me no it was the
wrong thing to do but you know my
teammate accepted it you know our ad you
know being habitat for the game I mean
coach Scoob had a chat before the game
and you know they big I would they
deserves two touchdowns and knocked the
[ __ ] out like I said we we absolutely
loved it on this show I mean we've been
a big fan for a while and one thing we
were wondering is you know you come from
Ohio and a lot of schools in the Big Ten
looked like they needed your help this
year how did you end up at Kentucky um
you know I had office Mary where you
know I just I was one of them guys that
I wanted to go change the program around
and I don't want I ain't want to go to a
big big-name school and just just be an
average guy you know don't get me wrong
no doubt in my mind if I went to one of
the bigger schools you know I I felt
like I still do the same thing but you
know I just wanted to showcase it at a
different level you know just coming
from one of the schools that that's
building and when I went there it was a
lot of our guys and even even some
Youngstown guys on the team outside of
the coaches you know I I knew everybody
on the team could relate to me because
they had same same mindset you know and
the same grit as me and we never looked
back from there because I was committed
to Indiana at first you know it was it
was nice place at indiana budget for
like it took you for me soul in when you
play Madden does that mean you're like
the Bengals like you just want to go the
worst team and make them better or is
that kind of what went into your mindset
no I see when I play man I played a
little more like there you go I just I
play I play with man like couple days
ago I beat somebody like 78 to 6 and the
more hair a dress and touchdowns on line
so not bad know that that's not bad at
all do you have a preference on teams or
like a region that you want to go to
obviously you're gonna be happy no where
no matter where you get drafted but do
you have a favorite team or a region
that you like to stay in you know my
favorite team is you know always I've
been a dollar still offenses
young but as far as a preference where I
go you know I just want to play now I
want to showcase the world you know
showcase to the guys there this is not
just because I went to Kentucky and not
because of the high school I went to you
know I want to I only could be to
compete against the top guys there isn't
any gaming football you know in this
game I love to play and I want to
showcase what I could do against them
guys and help one of these D teams to a
champion Super Bowl Lin how much did
having a son change your life and
motivate you because it's always cool to
see him on the field with you and all
that and it just seems like your game
has been taken to a completely different
level these last two years oh definitely
my son my son uh my wife you know me and
coach grant he he put that in my head
you always got to have wha you know and
I always had to watch since he was born
but you know he just he elevated me he
leveled me up you know this like right
now like besides the offseason training
that we did I could tuck he like so when
I'm getting ready for the draft is
literally the first training I ever had
in my life so I never trained like for
football ever in my life never trained
for basketball ever in my life besides
practices and offseason workouts and you
know so it was different you know just
having him it made me it made my drive
ten times more you know I had to make
sure like I had this model like how my
son go eat you know and if I ain't gonna
do it who gonna do it and I just want my
son to know that that I'm gonna be the
reason that he's gonna be okay well then
this is probably the podcast the
football podcast with the most tattoos I
feel pretty confident about that you are
a guy that had a couple yourself how
many tattoos do you have and what's your
next one that you're working on right
now I want to say I even got 74 75 and
more the next one I'm working on okay
there's a little more than we have here
don't worry
yeah but the next one I'm working on you
know I'm gonna get my stomach finished
it's gonna be all my jerseys throughout
my whole football career you know I'm
just gonna get them across my stomach
and fill up my stomach with those I
don't know if you've ever visited your
Wikipedia page but that's actually where
that camp comes from like on the
personal section it just says
Bowden has over 70 tattoos including one
of former Kentucky teammate Benny
Snell's tag line Snell yeah on his
stomach is that true you got Snell yeah
on your stomach you say they say say are
Peters you know they got a face in the
middle and that was my cousin died when
I was a partisan either high school or
middle school you know he's a big
influence on me playing football he yeah
I see one office to go out go out and
play football that's what I got across
my stomach Lane could we get any insight
what you think what you think you're
gonna run at the combine or is there
anything specific that that you're
trying to showcase everyone that you
think people are sleeping on right now I
think people just think I'm inconsistent
you know no I'm just going I'm just
gonna prove me wrong you keep proving
wrong like I've been doing all my life
so I just that's really what's okay and
last question for you man we'll let you
get back to training if they ask you to
workout a quarterback at the combine or
at a private workout with team is that
something you do I work on any position
any workout I'll never say no I like to
use a new open door that's awesome keep
that same energy you had before the
Virginia Tech game and good things are
gonna happen for you thank you so much
for calling in
good luck in Indy if we see you we will
not bump you in the hallway I promise
we'll be very nice yes sir I appreciate
it man I appreciate you know man has
always been a dream to be on here thanks
limply apollomon hope y'all follow me
back or thumb you know I definitely did
on both I'll get the rest of these guys
to catch up and we'll keep hyping you up
all right yes sir I appreciate it all
right later man
it is top five time we're doing
something a little bit different this
week we're under top five game changers
from the 2020 draft class and as Melo
clarified it this week in our group text
this not people who were gonna change
the game of football we're not talking
about Lamar Jackson or Patrick mahomes
or anyone like that
but guys who can change the game for
their the franchise that drafts them
change alike a single game yeah I
changed the game of
all right ea sports in the game although
one of the guys one of my guys Mike one
of your guys Mike let's start at number
five on my list offensive game changers
I don't know a Brandon I you from
Arizona State a guy I was so sad we
didn't get to see at the Senior Bowl cuz
I think he would have done very very
well here having time now to catch up on
2018 and 2019 tape from i uke and he's
he's just explosive if you get the ball
in his hands what he can do after the
catch is really really special I've
compared him to Sammy Watkins if you go
back to what Sammy looked like at
Clemson I think you get I you can a
system where he's not the best route
runner in this draft class but he's not
a bad route runner and I think sometimes
I guess lost there get him in a system
where yeah he's gonna want some schemed
touches but he can play inside he can
play outside he has good size with great
speed and one of those players who is
just better with the ball on his hands
he's gonna have some return ability as
well too for for any team that's
interested in him I'm gonna go in my
first game changer on the defensive side
of the football I'm going with Grant
Delpit at number five overall and I know
that he's been getting a lot of heat
lately a lot of his issues come because
he struggles with tackling or the
willingness to tackle but his coverage
ability is still very good and at six
foot three almost 210 pounds he can take
away it tighten it and he can take away
the slot receiver running backs out of
the backfield this is a guy that can
cover anywhere you want to he can
probably even line up outside again I
know that he's been taking a lot of heat
and I don't think that he's the safety
that we all thought he was going to be
but he's still damn good safety he's
gonna go in the first round and with
that height I really think that he's
gonna be a matchup dream for a lot of
these defensive coordinators you look at
like the AFC West matching up with guys
like Waller and Kelsey like the Chargers
might be looking for a guy like this and
how to pick number seven
I wouldn't think but you know the
Broncos kind of have theirs with their
safeties he's gonna have some value and
he's gonna be able to change the game
you're gonna be able to scheme him to at
least take away some targets alright
kicking off the special teams here he's
a this is a fun one guys I'm starting
with a kicker and I promise this will be
the only kicker on the game changers
list for special teams we're going with
Rodrigo hot rod
Blankenship now he didn't save his best
for last this year his field goal
percent is fumarole percentage was down
just a little bit but he's got a really
really strong leg I mean you go back to
his sophomore year where he went 20 of
23 that's 87 percent and the most
notable thing once again with him is not
only has he been really really accurate
from anything from 40 and below he does
have that strong leg to hit 50 to 55
yards out so I think if you're looking
for a kicker that will be drafted and
grades highly above everyone else it
starts and ends with blankenship mr. hot
rod himself the goggles yeah I mean
that's how everyone knows the number
first Malone what nickname is goalpost
Malone okay that's funny when I have to
explain the jokes man I'm the google it
I'm so old number four on my game
changers list ylvis' cachet no I talk
about brand new I you cuz it's like not
a terrible route runner Luis cachet and
all this not what I would call an
accomplished route runner he's gonna
have to really develop his game there
and I think one thing that we can look
at is DK Metcalfe wheat we joked we made
fun of he can run three routes well by
the end of the year with the Seahawks he
was running like seven or eight routes
and so I think with Chanel we want to
look at that and say can you also
develop as a route runner on the fly
sure you're gonna come in with a small
set of tools like a Liam Neeson and
you're gonna be able to do this really
well but over the course of now 17 or
how many ever games are planned can you
develop and get better at all these
different things and I think wish you
know he can come in and play slot he can
play outside and you're gonna want a
scheme touches to be a lot of crossing
routes to be a lot of jet sweeps or pop
passes a lot of bubble screens because
while he's not probably gonna dominate
in the 40 I think he's three Conan will
be great his short shuttle would be
great we'll see a lot of very good at
Jill Dee from shinola cuz that's what he
excels in and even if he doesn't test
great I think his tape shows he is like
a slippery type of playmaker like a
percy harvin type guy who just again
find ways to gave him the ball in space
I think you look at a lot of those teams
at the back into the first round the
Eagles the Saints the Chiefs even if
they could if he could get into one of
those offenses where they kind of use
him in that role I think it's gonna be
really good
for him and not just limiting to okay we
drafted you in the first round go play
outside receiver try to beat all this
past coverage number four for me is guy
who excels in press coverage and that's
Jeff Okuda I I put him on my list I went
back and I watched a little bit more
tape on John four CUDA I loved it so
much I'm moving him up to he's the
number two guy on my big board right now
anyway
yeah I'm sorry Joe burrow this is a
shutdown corner and he's perfect I don't
know what he can't do
he's six one two hundred pounds he can
press he can drop in zone he can guard
big receivers outside because he has
that speed and that size but he also has
the speed and the feet to keep up with
these little guys on the outside this is
a guy that can change a ballgame he can
take away a kuda Island a the best
shutdown corner I've seen since we
started this podcast since I started
helping you with the draft stuff I
absolutely love the sky like Patrick
Peterson is probably the comp or Jalen
Ramsey not a lot of corners have been
able to do what Jeff Koons defined
Gilmour on a comp for him but yeah he's
faster is any bigger than Gilmour - I
don't I don't think so I don't have his
like height weight right in front of me
but again six one two hundred pounds
that's a very big corner and then I
still expect him to run like four four
this is gonna be one of the best corners
we've ever seen I'm with you all the way
he's he's almost perfect when it comes
to a corner prospect that's how good he
is number four for me here going back to
the guys that kick this is punter Braden
man and I actually am excited about this
guy because he can actually flip a field
and we know how about how much that
really does matter he averages around 50
yards per punt throughout the entire
season he won the right guy award in
2018 he probably should have won it this
year I actually don't understand why he
was left off the semi-finalists but man
is he's a he's far and away the best
punter in this class a booming leg and I
do think he'll be one of the better
punters in the NFL very early in his
career how's our guy in Seattle doing
the old Texas punter Michael Dixon you
know he really good
he was quite pay attention to him this
year but his rookie year everybody is
like oh my God look at this punter he's
amazing oh yeah I know yeah he's he's
still doing things in c-axis
we're gonna punters and we're good and
Seattle that's about it yeah Seattle and
punters number three on my list may be
cheating here but
I gotta go my guy Jerry Judy like you
were just saying about Jeff akuto i feel
like jerry judy is if he were just a
little bigger cuz he is a little bit
skinny if he were a little bigger we'd
be talking about this is as good a
receiver since Julio Jones as it stands
I feel like Jerry is being overthought
because everyone oh well he played it
Bama with all that talent around him or
yeah two at quarterback or look what CD
Lam did everybody's like getting all hot
in the pants about all these other
receivers when Jerry's been the dude for
two years with the target share we
talked about earlier in the show the
guys he had around him CD Liam had
scrubs around him in Oklahoma for first
round receivers at least on that team
and and he's still the number one guy
yeah there were a couple body drops this
year I feel like we focus on that
because Jerry Judy was on TV every
Saturday at 2:30 on CBS and we watched
every game since I dropped on against
LSU I am not worried about it because I
don't think drops show up over the last
three years when you really get dig in
and study his tape so I think Jerry Judy
we don't see receivers come in a lot and
be fantastic as rookies Jerry Judy as
long as he doesn't go somewhere where
there is no quarterback he should walk
into the NFL and be a very good receiver
immediately because he's so agile e so
fast the burst out of his routes Tim and
how good he is as a pure route runner I
can't imagine this guy just not being a
stud day one yeah I agree with you I
think that given the right situation he
could come in and easily be you know
1,000 yard receiver in his rookie year
again situation matters so don't hold me
to that but I do think he could be that
guy number three for me I'm gonna take
you back to a simpler time the end of
December when they are handing out
college football awards the Thorpe Award
went to a gentleman by the name of grant
Delpit that award should have went to
Antoine Winfield junior he's gonna be my
next game-changer here yes he is
undersized but in his first season at
Minnesota where he was fully healthy
this dude had 83 tackles three sacks
seven interceptions and two forced
fumbles he has a nose for the football
he's not afraid to get in there get
dirty make the tackles but he's also
great in coverage I think he can play
nickel
I think he can fly single high maybe if
he packs on some weight I think he can
even play strong saftey he's listed at
5:10 2:05 I want to see what he measures
in at the combine and I think he's
probably gonna be 5 9 and some change
and I think he's gonna struggle to break
200 pounds but the game tape is there
the Heritage there with his father
playing Antoine Winfield for the Vikings
for so long and being a player in the
league if he stays healthy we're talking
about a first-round guy and you guys
talked about that on the midweek show -
like if it weren't for health this would
be a first round safety I think that he
can be that guy I want to see what he
does at the combine but he has already
changed the game at the college level
win on the field he's one of the best
safeties in the name doesn't it feel
like it's gonna be like a one thornhill
type situation or like a Taylor rap
where he's gonna fall today - and
somebody's gonna steal him and we're
gonna be like why does the NFL let this
happen we're gonna go back and look at
this draft in 2025 am i oh yeah [ __ ]
wila Antoine Winfield goes to the second
round why like he'll go to the Steelers
or something you know they go great
great this again yeah I'm with you all
the way I mean he's got a lot of you
know honey badger Buddha Baker that
undersized safety that just shows up
everywhere on the fields in his game
number three now we could have some fun
with the special teams we're done with
the guys to kick the ball out there on
to the guys that's the on to the guys
that score the touchdowns and I got one
actually from Matt's list that makes it
on special teams as well here - and
that's Brandon IU IU quietly we know how
good he was as a receiver this year we
know he's probably one of the most
explosive players in this class after
the catch but quietly he was a very very
good kick and punt returner this year
for Arizona State he averaged 32 yards
per kick return per kick return and on
punts he averaged over 16 yards per punt
return he's brought one back to the
house very consistent punt return option
he's the guy that just seems to get you
that 10 to 12 yards every single time he
touches the ball cuz he always makes the
first guy miss very explosive player so
I think we've done a very good job on
this show illustrating how special I you
can be as a receiver because he's a
little raw but you know we can win deep
he's effective on screens slants out
routes but a lot of people forget this
guy
made things happen consistently on
special teams for that Arizona State
program yeah and I'm really coming
around on him he's just I think as we
get to this time of year you can search
imagine guys like outside of the boxes
that we put prospects in and like man if
we could get a Yukon he's probably not
gonna be but like if he were in the
Niners offense or the Rams offense the
Chiefs the Eagles like somewhere where
you can be creative with him you could
have a lot of fun number two for me
DeAndre swift again we're talk about
game changers at the running back
position I know there was a moment time
there where I was like yeah JK Dobbins
looks pretty good sometimes I'm an idiot
DeAndre Swift is welcome back back in
this class wait wait wait wait wait you
are going back to Swift oh I am yeah
okay I like it well I what happen to you
there the injury bothered me that was a
night I think I said that when it
happened I was like God the injury
bothers me it did and I think with Swift
like if in three years were like man the
shoulders a big problem he's got
arthritis we'll be like well [ __ ] I
should have stuck with JK dominance but
he's just so explosive and I think again
as we get out of the box of you know
okay you vision got it outside zone
inside Sun God I got it speed got it
Swift just does everything a little bit
better than all the other backs in this
class so like with Dobbins I got really
excited because I think he has a little
more power than Swift at the point of
contact but Swift is faster he has
better open field vision he has better
hands the routes that he runs out of the
backfield are more nuanced and Jake from
legitimately generous which saved his
life
so many times so I think with Dobbins
yeah it was like the playoff run it was
man he's doing some really good things
to it's good defenses and we saw him
down the stretch gets your Penn State in
Michigan his offensive line no
disrespect to Georgia what Ohio State's
offensive line was doing I think made JK
Dobbins job a little bit easier so Swift
is the top running back for me and a lot
of it is just because and we've talked
about this with quarterbacks privately
and I think on the show the league is
changing and as we adapt to how the
league is changing you have to have
someone like DeAndre Swift
like that is what everyone wants and I
know Dobbins catches the ball just find
out
backfield Jonathan Taylor caught the
ball better this year Clyde the glide
catches the ball well again Swift just
does all the things that I wanted a
running back a little bit better than
those guys yeah that's good to have you
back yeah welcome we can start talking
about how tiandra Swift is running back
one first stick to football again it's
nice to be able to say that one more
thing I will say okay fine I know a lot
of people are like oh you're like you're
flip-flopping that is like the process
and I would rather say like hey I
watched more tape and I thought a more
about where the NFL's going with
positional traits and I changed my mind
then saying nah in December I said JK
Dobbins and I'm gonna stick with that so
if you want to be one of those people
that tweets that says all you guys are
flip-flopping on prospects we are
because we're still working our asses
off no studies plans
I just dropped Jo burrow on my board
because I watched more Jeff Okuda STUV
it it happens all the time so use the
app button shift two on your keyboard
you don't have to take screenshots okay
use that number two on my list is
actually probably a surprise I'm going
with chase Young here as a game changer
because well no duh this guy wrecked
every game and don't give me that
[ __ ] this was another take by a very
popular draft guru said he didn't know
what happened to chase Young in the last
three games in the season god I [ __ ]
kidding one of the most popular draft
guys and say you don't know what
happened to chase young in the last
three games of the season I'll tell you
what happened they triple teamed him
literally I don't think he saw anything
less than a double team so yeah he
didn't have any sex this is still one of
the best edge wrestlers we've ever seen
now I don't care how long you've been
doing it put him near the top he is
going to be an excellent NFL player
alright I'll wrap this up with my final
two on the special teams I'm actually
surprised Matt that you didn't have this
guy on yours but it's a tough year
somebody isn't gonna make the cut Jalen
Rieger here now I think he did a lot
more in college as a receiver but for
special teams I do think he's a really
really explosive putter
Turner it's just all about opportunities
with Rieger when they actually choose to
kick to him he is really really fast the
acceleration is phenomenal I mean four
three speed there and he makes guys miss
so I really really like Rieger because I
think he's gonna get more opportunities
as a specialist at the next level as
well
the final one a name that you probably
haven't heard on this show yet but he
had a fantastic career at Virginia as a
kick returner and that's Joe Reed I'm
curious to see how Reed doesn't the
combine if he's gonna test very well
because he's a very explosive returner
five kicks brought back four touchdowns
throughout his college career two this
year and most importantly guys he
averaged over 33 yards per kick returns
so yeah you love the five touchdowns you
like the ability to really change the
game and bring one back to the house but
you also love a guy that was
consistently getting it out to the 50
yard line time and time again so Joe
Reed I don't know if he's gonna play
much receiver at the next level I did
think he had a really really nice final
season but he will make an NFL team as a
return man I have him as draftable means
oh yeah shrine game guy combine and buy
I think he's draftable last on my list
Joe burrow and I feel like this is
incredibly obvious even though Melo
hates Joe Baro that's why I moved him
down Yeah right I think like Joe burrow
is another guy where it's funny because
he came along and it was like he he
warmed up warmed up warmed up and then
boom he blew up and now it's almost come
around where people like to is better
than him
I don't think he is and I I will say hi
might be wrong here I put burrow above
to uh during the LSU Alabama game and
this was before to his injury I just
feel like burrow was so special with his
accuracy my favorite thing about him
though is when pressured and it happened
a lot LSU's often sublime it's not as
good as a lot of people want to make
them out to be when he was pressured his
ability to move and keep his eyes
downfield I've said it before it reminds
me of my homes and I know people are
going to think that's sacrilegious
because burrows arm is not that strong
but I mean in the way he feels pressure
and then it really doesn't rattle him I
know there was a great quote from an LSU
coach who said a lot of guys when they
get hit hard they kind of wilt and they
don't want it with Joe gets hit hard
just pisses him off and he plays better
I love that about him and I think that's
why wherever he lands in the NFL that
trait is gonna carry him that ability
that oh I just got rocked okay who cares
let's do it again
I mean his whole career was built on
getting the [ __ ] kicked out of him by
UCF in the bowl game and then we saw
what happened with him last guy on my
list is obviously going to be Isiah
Simmons we were talking about it before
these are game changers that could
change a single game this is a
linebacker that I do think can change
the game of football I think that he can
come in as a defensive weapon and a lot
of teams start to look at I need one of
those give me a guy who is a big safety
or give me a linebacker that can cover
like him the problem is we haven't seen
one since I've been doing this so Isaiah
Simmons is the true game changer
I think in this entire draft I mean
we've been saying it all along his
unicorn we haven't seen anything like
him he's gonna change the game of
football
not just a single game he's the game
change yest of all the game changers I
do want to ask were you guys ranking him
because I have never done this I put lb
/s I thought about doing that today's I
just don't and they're gonna beat me
would I can I have him in as a
linebacker because he's six for 230 but
I wouldn't be surprised if some team
drafts him and they even announce safety
out of Clemson Isiah Simmons like it
could just go so many different ways
with him yeah I'm anxious to see because
I don't think it's been announced what
position group he's working with at the
combine Yeah right we need to look into
that if it has been a nice smart it's
the linebackers oh yeah he's just gonna
excel in coverage I'm trying to run
faster than everyone else look better
than everyone else
yeah it is at linebacker so okay I went
down a rabbit hole while we were talking
sorry fellows I was trying to pay
attention here but I've looked at some
betting odds for 40 times I couldn't
find his but one that really stood out
to me was Jonathan Taylor they have him
at four five one yeah he's going for
four well they have nori rugs at four
three eight yes three you take the Owen
they take the under on that one yeah I
do that on Monday show I always find
some good just go through all the
combine prop bets although I don't know
if I want to give away the money secret
you're in Jersey right you so you will
hasn't released them yet sadly but I'm
hoping they do next week
so if I've in mo you know okay I mean
gambling I don't do that stuff that's
right that's dangerous
we'll be back right after this all right
it is draft on draft time first question
from a great user named moose and Hanks
dad I hope those are they aren't dog
they have to be there better be dogs
questions on the show really okay should
say that all right one of the rebel no
cats right right
what prospect are you high on that no
one knows about yet what prospects are
you currently watching so I am trying to
get caught up I on LSU I know that
sounds weird right like that any tuned
guys so I'm trying to go back through I
just just finished completely finished
Kayla on chase on watch Rashard Lawrence
this morning and so a Christian Fulton
was last week so I'm trying to work
through LSU which takes it actually
takes a long time for a team that plays
that many games in a season to get
through 18 prospects so just be
transparent I'm on them a player I like
that I don't think anyone else is
talking about that's always tough I like
John Hiatt are from Boise State a lot I
think he's gonna do really really well
at the combine he wasn't a senior bowl
guy was a Jew tackle right not receiver
receiver John hi terrible was it tackle
to him Ezra Cleveland there's a little
more transparency state so I like John
Hightower a lot I like Daniel Thomas
he's a safety from Auburn and it was an
accident I was trying to watch Marlin
Davidson and I kept noticing this safety
against Alabama making all these plays
and was like who is number 24 so I look
him up I was like oh my god he's a
senior why wasn't he in an all-star game
I have no idea but he got a combine
invite so I'm excited I like Dana I
think he I mean he walks up a lot I
think he's probably a strong safety but
I'm you know as happens
I've already told a couple teams about
him like hey this dude might be late but
keep an eye on him because I think he's
pretty good it's hard to do the no one
else knows about it yet because I felt
like for a while I was running the cam
dance latrine and then I other
people are starting to catch on to as
they watch more tape I won't act like
I'm you know found the diamond in the
rough but as far as like other guys that
people don't know about yet that I'm
high on I don't know because like the
three of us talked so much and I feel
like those names are out there so
there's not really anybody that I feel
like I'm higher on that nobody knows
about as far as who I'm watching right
now I'm trying to get through the
safeties I liked Kyle Duggar a lot more
than I thought I would obviously our guy
Antoine Winfield jr. really liked him I
think this is gonna round out to be a
pretty decent safety class I don't think
there's a lot of top in talent after
Delpit and McKinney
but there are some def pieces some guys
that are gonna contribute that can play
free and strong safety and maybe even
some nickel but I'm watching a lot of
those guys right now yeah I'm with you
on the it's tough to get a player in
that nobody has heard of like the the
one guy say that I like a lot and I
never see him post it on Twitter
anywhere I guess had it that's how to
gauge it is Jay Jay Taylor the little
running back at Arizona and I say that
it's like it's like round six or seven
well considering he's five six I'm
pretty impressed with him running the
ball twenty five thirty times the game
and consistently you know generating
yards created at creating yards after
contact so I think that's one that I'm
excited about that you won't really hear
much because there's so many running
backs in this class and he's really
really small but it wouldn't shock me if
he's someone that sticks is a third
running back somewhere in a return man
Who am I watching now I've been working
through the offensive lineman and I feel
pretty good about my final stack of the
top guys and I think I was reading
something from you the other day where I
think we almost had it the same where
and melih I'd be curious your take on
this but I think wills is in his own
tier I really like wharfs like more than
I thought it's like listen I was I was
like man I think works cuz of like
limitations and this nate'll probably
the fourth he's number two clear-cut
offensive lineman Becton and Thomas are
so different but they're in the same
tier and I think that's what I saw from
you Matt where I felt exactly the same
and then Josh Jones is solid but I don't
think he
with any of those guys that's the thing
for me and and guys like Austin Jackson
I have really serious concerns about him
being on the field next year I think
he's truly a developmental guy Isiah
Wilson is someone who I'm pretty high on
coming out of Brooklyn here with pretty
much in all world ceiling but still some
development into developmental to go so
the tackle class for me is who I've been
working through and I feel pretty good
about that stack right now but I'll get
through the bottom tier guys later on I
have I have mine stacked the same way
though I have wills and I do think that
he's in a tier of his own but then works
he is making a late push you know we
talk about transparency and out like
what we do
I mean sometimes I'll watch a game and
I'll move a guy up or I'll move a guy
down and then sometimes I'll watch the
same damn game again Mao I didn't see
this the first time around we're not
machines just set to watch everything
and analyze every play sometimes we miss
things
so yeah worse it's kind of making his
way back up my board number three I have
Andrew Thomas as well I think at a
minimum this is a guy that's gonna play
Garden League for a long time right
tackle maybe develop into a left tackle
I like him I like him in the first round
I have Josh Jones next Makai Becton
scares the [ __ ] out of me because I
think he could be Eric flowers I think
that he could be oh yeah let's yeah I
went there I think he drafted pretty
high and he could fizzle out and we'll
look at him and be like why did we draft
this guy so high we talked about
revisiting old drafts I think we're
gonna look at it and say man this guy
had a lot of potential but he didn't do
[ __ ] with it or this little clip outs
gonna bite me in the ass and he's gonna
get all pro and everybody's just say
what the hell were you thinking how'd
you miss the six foot seven 370 pound
all-pro tackle so it's just which player
are we gonna get because scenario it's
so important for him is he gonna get in
there with a line that's good and that
can develop him or is he gonna go like
Cleveland number 10 and he's gonna be
dog [ __ ] and you just you never know so
it's early I'm a little low on Becton
right now I tweeted it out if he gets
his hands on you you are done it's over
yep but he doesn't get his hands on a
lot of people and there are way too many
plays I see we talked about like the
highlight kinks there are a lot
clip out of him against that Clemson
game I saw a lot of games I'm sorry a
lot of snaps of him at Clemson and he
was doing this he didn't know where to
go and he wasn't running to get anybody
but if you were right there in front of
him boom you are dead but he wasn't
getting to that second level he wasn't
doing much in the past rut so Mekhi
Becton I'm up and down on him I think
I'm lower on Becht and then a lot of
people draft Twitter everybody that you
see I have him at 48 on my board right
now I have him pretty low I love that
though I mean I think that was a 2020
draft resolution from all of us was to
make your board your board and like whoo
yeah I mean I'm mellow I have him 25th
so I the concerns are there now with
that being said you make the point of if
he turns into an all-pro tackle it
wouldn't shock anyone here no but I do I
am curious about countermoves at the NFL
level and I would love to see if I could
see anything before the draft I just
want to see him and Caleb on chase on
them one-on-ones because a bendy guy
that can dip like that is what has me a
little concerned at the next level a guy
that can hit you with speed and power
because if you just walk back to him
with speed you're probably done but if
you have a little bit of both which if
you're in the NFL you do I think that
you could beat him and I like see gross
Matos as well because he has a little
pop to his game chase on I moved up to
10 overall I love him and it's just one
of those things like I said I'm just
gonna love who I love and if the NFL
says differently I'll let you guys know
you know we'll be transparent about this
what we're hearing versus what we're
seeing but he's 10 on my board now yeah
I have him at 11 I've been trying to go
through and put comps for guys okay yeah
right I have I comped him to merciless
how do you like the I did Josh Allen
yeah I don't like to do recent guys but
he drops into coverage soft yeah I agree
with you I just try to stay away from
like the guys that are one or two years
drafted I was sending mellow clips at
like 10 the other night I'm sitting on
my couch watching chase on just texting
him clip you love this I really do
alright we got another draft on draft
question here our guy Charlie maliska
since the combine is really about
interviews and medicals which player do
you think has the most to gain from
interviews and outside of - of the - of
who has the most games
medicals so I will say on the interview
side guys I think it is the
quarterback's Justin Herbert we've heard
for three years that he might not be a
great leader might be a little soft so
dude who played a high school football
Eugene Oregon but college should want
Eugene Oregon so getting him out of his
comfort zone I think would be pretty big
and then Jacob Eason as well I mean
everything that happened at Georgia from
the rumors that are out there that I
don't want to get into cuz they're just
rumors but then also things like how he
handled losing the job to Jake from
going to Washington sitting behind what
was that the little quarterback why did
I just go oh my gosh the little dreamer
backs name yeah I want to call it Jake
Bentley but I know that's not it behind
Washington's quarterback I think East
and the interviews gonna be big medicals
I mean name is everybody the medicals
are huge I mean it's the ones that you
know about then there's always the ones
that you don't know about that there's
always surprises so I think that's a big
one too
Jake browning thank you Jake browning I
think you're right when you talk about
quarterbacks though especially Herbert
for some weird reason quarterbacks that
are really smart get lumped into this do
they care about football thing now we
saw it with Josh Rosen and we've seen it
numerous times
Justin Herbert's a very smart kid
academically I think that there's gonna
be some questions around that too I mean
it seems like teams just always do that
thing I don't know why but oh he's very
smart
does he love football oh he has other
interest why does he have other interest
because he's a [ __ ] human being and
he likes more than just football yeah I
think when you look at you know
something we just talked about with Lynn
is that teams last about stuff like that
although teams like that stuff like they
don't care that you're feisty before the
game they like that kind of energy that
just falls back into what Melo said you
love football
yeah a little go out yeah people to
knock you the [ __ ] out he likes football
our Darrius Stewart got drafted guys
okay like yeah our dairy Stewart Google
that one if not it will be my book that
book will come out when I retire from
doing this job
it's called stories I couldn't tweet and
it will be in there
so I think the interviews I mean
interviews you're huge for everybody you
know we've heard stories about I mean
this is like our Rubin Foster got kicked
out of the combine should have been a
pretty big red flag still what first
round and hopefully he turns his life
around eventually
but last question this is a great one
Andrew Magnuson asked us this if you
could observe three teams war room for
this draft which three would you pick I
want to say quickly I hate that
terminology I hate war room and I know
like that's what we call it though but I
don't like it anyway neither here nor
there
I would number one for me would actually
be the Bengals because there would be a
ton of seats and a lot of snacks because
they might have like four people and
byof your own snacks a Google sheet you
have the free chair
it's potluck so I'll bring the Smokies
but I think the bangles would be
fascinating just to see how they how
they handle this draft I think that
would be one for me the Dolphins are
projected to have thirteen picks after
compensatory selections are announced
that would be another good one just
because they're not gonna have a break
their first round is gonna be so busy
like obviously pick five is gonna be
very stressful or if they move up but
then on the flip going from let's say
they stay at five five to eighteen
there's a lot of work that has to be
done during that time to get ready for
your next pick and then again in the
third round or sorry two picks in the
second round it's gonna be crazy
those are my two Cincinnati Miami New
England in New England cuz boring okay
are they gonna move on from Brady are
they drafting for now or for the future
I think that's interesting my first one
I won't steal three teams in a row my
first one is gonna be the Raiders though
I really want yeah I think I I would
pick them first I love what they've been
doing with the draft I know they sent
all their scouts home last year I was
like oh what the [ __ ] are they doing
yeah they've had a very good draft so
it's working I like to see Mayock and
Gruden work their magic and what they're
doing and to just get confirmation that
they're really targeting those guys that
are just a dog in a champion in winter I
want to see what that looks like and
also kind of like with the dolphins they
have two picks for the first round so
they're gonna be very busy
they could also target a quarterback I
don't think they will if you listen to
this show you know that they're going to
receiver and running back
the airside receiver and linebacker in
the first round so I I would pick the
Raiders first yeah I can't argue with
that one that'll be a fun one to watch I
guess I'll go with the Giants just so I
can watch two things what I need to get
inside the mind of Dave gentlemen Justin
go how he operates I would sit there and
just stare at him the entire night the
other thing is I need to know if when
the player falls to them that they
really like if they truly unplug the
phones remember that story what say yeah
yeah yeah I find that insane
I don't think Joey says you use that
name component to call in your pic so I
don't know how they're getting around
that so like a heart is it like a
landline yeah it is doing these do the
helmet phones oh yeah I love oh I wish I
had one of my I'm gonna [ __ ] look on
eBay right we got to find those they got
to exist still all those the landline
because I don't want anyone calling me
oh yeah it couldn't be functional I
don't see any on Amazon that's for
another day boys anyway the other team
that I would be very curious to sit in
on would be the Carolina Panthers
obviously there's a lot of change there
right now and I have no idea where
they're going with their pick they might
go quarterback I think Cody line there's
just so many different directions I
would want to sit in and see how this
new coaching staff runs the draft they
can be patient they don't have to reach
for a quarterback I love what their
owners doing so the Panthers are
probably my second pick at number seven
overall I think it's gonna be exciting
for my second one I'd go with the
Cowboys I want to see if the Jones
family truly lets Wilma clay just just
operate in his own way with the scouts
or if there are is there interference
there and I think with Dallas at 17 man
there's a lot of directions they can go
I know every time we do a mock draft
I've been putting Xavier McKinney there
and actually had someone one of their
listeners of the show Joe DeMaio asked
hey could they trade back and still get
McKinney I wouldn't feel comfortable
with that and I think McKinney is far
and away shown he's the top safety in
this class and well worthy of a top 20
selection
I mean Dallas you know the spreads gonna
be good like Jerry's getting like James
take yeah yeah good you know I'm their
family draft night I got
you know yeah especially in the first
round I'm picking a third team I'm kind
of torn I'm gonna with the Titans cuz I
want to hang out with Rabil and I think
that that would be a good time and to
have them picking at Twentynine they
could go quarterback we'll see what
happens with Tannehill maybe you could
get some inside scoops what's gonna go
on with Derrick Henry and they've been
pretty exciting on the draft too I mean
last year they even taken the defensive
linemen every seventh Jeffrey Simmons
when a lot of people didn't think he'd
go first round that worked out pretty
well he was okay and his second half his
rookie season pretty good football
player yeah my last one would probably
be the Colts I would like to see just
chris ballard and ed Dodds go to work
and I'll tell you what this picket
thirteen is complete mystery right now I
know Colts fans want a quarterback
we'll see if Anthony Costanzo retires
because if he does they need a tackle
and I think it would be and they also
trade all the time I feel like they
traded their pick every single year so
I'm very curious to see what the Colts
do at 13 yeah right now they have nine
picks with competitive so they should
not trade back they should trade up they
have they have that picket thirteen they
have 34 and they have 44 so there would
be busy early the Colts would be a good
one as well all right that is our show
thanks to Lynn Bowden one of the more
fun interviews we've we've been able to
have I appreciate his honesty a lot of
guys like uh it's a misunderstanding and
let's move on he was like no I'm a man
and you bumped me he's a one stole [ __ ]
out of my car I was pissed off I'm gonna
like try to find him in India and like
just give him a little shoulder no
you're not go ahead Melo show for a
couple weeks when you have a broken jaw
like Kanye jaw wired shut
God okay that's our show we will be back
Monday morning a combine preview with
the trio and then we are on to
Indianapolis where I'm going to eat
steak every [ __ ] night we'll see you
guys then